mais tellement mal comme toi si ce
monsieur n'a fait beaucoup de bruit mais
c'est rien a dit koné chez pas nous
écouter garder le vôtre si c'est mon
mari non moi moi c'est ma copine avant
elle investit un ascenseur vous savez
vous d'écouter le prêt de son
appartement pour 15 jours avec des
partis en vacances bon moi j'arrive
qu'est ce que je trouve rien non elle
m'avait même pas laissé son mari jamais
failli et le charmant heureusement
qu'ils voient dans les escaliers je vais
rencontrer un barbu marie aussi et barbu
je ne connaissais même pas enfin je veux
dire
une demi-heure avant je ne connaissais
pas mais une heure après et pendant
quinze jours on a fait connaissance sais
rien mais alors ma copine elle se plaint
alors que qui sait qu'il va garder sa
place au chaud dans son livre la carte
d'humour basse et moi n'avons plus barbu
au but on l'a déjà dit elle se plaint
que soit disant que la baignoire c'est
pas un cendrier que les rhinos asavpa
casse mushi que jamais pas apporté son
vision au cloud alors que moi il me
restait plus un radis alors que moi je
laisse des nouilles monde a remué bah
oui mais je le comprends très bien mais
vous savez et des gens c'est incroyable
comme quoi l'amitié
moi je vois 15 ans de mariage dans les
mêmes eaux
je pars qu'un jeu oui c'est pour
beaucoup
non ça fait 2 mais bon je mentais
j'annonce à mon mari que maman n'est pas
morte
donc pas d'héritage il s'est mis dans
une colère au west ham est alors quand
je lui dis comment aller mieux
c'était de pire en pire alors est ce que
c'est une parole amène aux paroles qu'a
mené notre parole sami notre parole
fausse affaire gros mot alors cet homme
là est devenue rouge de colère c'était
épouvantable
alors quand je lis que moment lévirat
maison convalescence des routes aulas
était terminée et voilà et voilà et
voilà mais c'est un amour transmettant
leur fabuleux mais c'est un passe-temps
delahousse avait marqué je le comprends
cet homme là non c'est vrai s'ils
s'attendent à son héritage et belhadj
est déçu qu'il n'y a rien de pire que
les espoirs déçus vraiment attendre qu
est ce que je vais faire je vais quand
même pas me faire payer mais pas le jour
à nos commerçants s'arrête en panne avec
le monde qui va et qui vient ça les fait
installer pas être tranquille tu vois je
me sentirai jamais chez moi même je sais
pas pour vous proposer parce que moi je
pars acapulco avec mon bar buts et à
leurs abords il attendait une rentrée
d'argent qui m'a dit d'être récupéré le
fric et brahim emmené acapulco
voilà c'est bien mais j'y pense des voix
vous à était allé dans son appartement
n'est pas là orvoine ont aussi une bonne
de vous le pratiquez vous il reste aux
femmes chez sorbonne au passage chez des
copines de validation des copies d'euros
alors moi je la vis de votre barbu là
oussalah l'a7 pour bien me placer un
plat cette porte là c'est la porte je
suis sorti un peu ça moi chez toi
vous savez pas mais moi je sais moi j'ai
acapulco l'héritage ma meilleure tout ça
c'est moi enfin c'est mon modèle c'est
bêtement ici votre mari mais c'est mon
rôle c'est mon voisin connaissez votre
voisin ne sais mon arrêt mais c'est
votre voisin mais c'est quand même mon
mari à l'époque celle là je vous propose
dans un appartement pendant que mes
parties avec un peu confuse vous serez
chez vous chez vous alors que ce que
vous voulez plus
apave alors c'est la meilleure celle là
un an passé la meilleure foule alors moi
je pars deux semaines pendant 15 jours
pour faire mourir la narine pétales se
marier qui pourra me marier avec
acapulco 10,7 à venir d'un pape en soit
la val a rappelé simplice touchant prêté
son appartement dans les palaces en
voilà ce soit vous allez maintenant tout
est alors je vous vois
à balad et corey maggette en chercher
d'autres
bon au commencement dieu s'ennuyait le
sexe des anges ça va cinq minutes
ces gens là on sait jamais par kelkoo
les ponts à force de se tourner les
pouces il eu des ampoules aux mains ce
qui lui donna une idée que la lumière
soit et la lumière fut
en ça marche le deuxième jour dieu créa
la mer et les continents et les
incontinents le troisième jour dieu
inventa les animaux comestibles et il
vit que cela était bon et une queue de
cochon vos malheurs et poitrine fraîche
pour monsieur
le quatrième jour dieu créa les plantes
le matin les philodendron l'après-midi
les rhododendrons et la nuit les
édredons le cinquième et le sixième jour
il créa le reste je tout le reste soit
et tout le reste fut est le 7e jour il
se repose un bon travail de dieu ouais
norme c'est peu de chose vous savez il
ya encore mal de choses à faire un héros
de son pot good run et j'ai pas brancher
le téléphone mais lieu le lundi suivant
déjà commencé à s'ennuyer
ça va dieu bof ça va comme un lundi
moi j'en ai marre les arbres les
prairies les montagnes tout ça ça
commence à me lasser
moi je suis quelqu'un de la ville
j'aimerais bien y faire une partie de
big bang ou jouer à saute mouton mais il
faudra un partenaire et bien créé un
adieu
oui mais je ne sais pas comment me pro
veille du bac ou capi ligety attendez je
crois que j'ai une idée
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande la
plus grande attention
nous sommes un instrument un reportage
direct sur dieu qui est en train de
faire les gestes qu'ils ont rendus
célèbres à une fête à paraître c'est le
prêtre est bonne celle des épaules
larges un buste puissant des jambes à
corte presse agaçant d'appétit dirait
digne de respect il a une démarche
dynamique
je peux vous dire maintenant que c'est
un français le voilà mesdames de
l'essonne il s'appelle adam sont bien
bravo merci
adam janvier content d'être là ouais je
voudrais profiter de l'occasion pour
remercier ma famille et tous ceux qui
m'ont aidé en arriver là quoi a bien
hâte en janvier vous auriez pu mettre le
maillot jaune
euh bah oui c'est vrai parce que je suis
pro dieu a dans son billet à dieu qu'est
ce que vous comptez faire pour votre
poulain dont il se débrouille tout seul
là je suis passée vincent de paul ou
qu'est ce que vous allez faire dans son
billet attendez je voudrais dire deux
mots à dieu non quoi as tu une fameux à
une femme bah oui comment faire bah
c'est bête parce qu'il y en a qui dépend
c'est là tout à l'heure si j'avais su je
leur ai demandé son téléphone mon bep
couture reste là hein je vais essayer de
la reconstituer de mémoire 1
alors ne bouge pas je vais à mon avis
pas comme ça tu vas ça
john boehner alors en ce temps là les
jeunes je vous laisse tourner de
tranquille dans le jardin surtout vous
rester là et interdiction d'aller boire
un verre de cidre au bistrot d'à côté
alors vous avez caché au fond de vous
sortez noir nommé à sa place à des
malpolis au sol a dit david alan ciao
elle lui avait tapé dans l'oeil
bonjour là bonjour au bistrot world
attention à temps c'est interdit par
dieu écoute parce qu'on dit adam vas-y
dont le patron est très simple un jeu
plutôt que tueur grenoble laog ce
serpent un divers adore
le jeune serveur indique aussi mettre sa
tête du can pas où ça va obliger tous
signalés çà et là
bien le bonjour à votre d'armes alors
les jeunes sa bannière travail ou lundi
dont trois proches et amis à elle tout
at on voit l'or souffle là dedans
positif tête et au bistrot du port les
yeux lui sont très bons je suis allé
mais seulement obligé puisque c'est
comme ça tous les deux vous chasse bon
alors toi dont tu prends tes 39 heures
chez renault quittent achètera une
maison fait note qui tiendra debout 15
ans et puis tu penseras des vacances en
famille à la tranche-sur-mer toi f qui
fera la boniche les lessiver le ménage
et en fera dans la douleur avec la main
finalement dieu vous n'êtes quand
infiniment bon ben on finira en bon
c'est mon fils qui a raconté ça n'a
jamais été vrai
bonjour moi je pensais même chose samedi
offrant six nouveaux penseurs français
ça va si bien
non ma c4 parce que ce séjour français
non pour le sketch et vaut mieux pas
parce que sinon ça va durer tout bon
alors je vous ai réunis aujourd'hui pour
la réunion
oui la réunion comment ce n'est pas ce
que quelqu'un du tabac march sens pas
bien je voyais donc pour la réunion de
la mjc une réunion annuelle que l'on
organise tous les ans au bout des
besoins de le travail c'est pour faire
un bilan de la mjc de notre commune
alors je vais faire un tour de table
l'atelier poterie francis car il est
maintenant de cette année et bien
francis e tu vois je crois que nous
avons toujours été franc les envers les
autres alors je vais faire le bilan
franchement tu vois et je suis devant un
échec
je suis donnera un échec je lave ou mon
projet de confectionner en poterie des
faucilles et des marteaux pour répondre
à la fête de l'huma n'a pas abouti je me
suis trouvé devant deux problèmes un
problème pratique d'abord c'est à dire
qu'il y avait le nombre d'etf aussi ne
correspondait pas au nombre des marteaux
et deuxièmement j'ai eu un problème de
motivation de la part des adhérents et
ils ont tout cassé
j'ai gardé un mois et
ça n'a pas vraiment marché comme
j'aurais voulu tuer ses deux procès
est-ce que tu ne crois pas que pour ton
atelier poterie lé tu as un petit peu
payé les pots cassés pour ta gestion de
mai dernier c'est possible et donc tu
étais éléments ont été détectés il cite
des cas les fichiers l'insertion sociale
assez difficile du bois dans le milieu
culturel de la maison de jeunes de la
commune tous d'accord bien je prends
note peu tout ce que tu viens de dire
merci à toi francine pour l'atelier de
danse musique
oui bah moi contrairement à francis ça
s'est plutôt bien passé parce que mon
effectif n'a pas changé oui bon accueil
prochaine
à la rigueur on peut s'attendre
peut-être à une petite progression
peut-être on se gare n'a certes occuper
d'autre chose que l'atelier honda perd
il n'y a pas eu vraiment de progression
un peu mais c'est qu'on va dépenser
peut-être élargir l'atelier en mettant
peut-être un atelier cuisine
we dance music cuisine voilà bien des
cas ferait aussi parallèlement à la
cuisine mettre aussi un atelier régime
parce que j'ai peur que le cours de
danse alors là ça marche est d'accord on
va obtenir danse musique cuisine régime
ça me paraît bien grand de la femme
aussi étonné que tu n'as pas d'élèves
qui peut occuper de ça et de toute façon
j'ai téléphoné au maire il me dit tu
aurais pas de problème cette année on
aura des plus de fric en plus de
subventions de ses chroniques
bien en ce qui te concerne l'atelier
judo littérature et bien l'atelier judo
littérature ça s'est très très bien
passé on a travaillé un petit peu sur de
nouveaux ateliers parce que j'aime bien
diversifié un petit peu sur l'atelier
recherche et découverte de l'inconnu
on a travaillé un petit peu je ne vous
cacherai rien en vous disant toute la
partie recherche s'est très bien passé
pour ce qui est laïque ouverte
on est en train d'évoluer mais j'espère
pourquoi pas arriver à des résultats
prochainement le dire la place encore
dans ton atelier écoute je crois que ces
chats nous restons ouverts le plus
possible n'est ce pas pour accueillir
c'est l'esprit de l'est de la libye
c'est parce que les chars je vous
rappelle que m6 et doit être une maison
devenue ont fait une maison des jeunes
et de la culture déjà prêt
il y en a un qui me concerne moi je vais
monter quatre pièces de brecht l'année
dernière je vais changer radicalement
pour cette année puisque je vais monter
cinq pièces de brecht lorsque c'est un
bon choix tu vois pas ce que j'aime tes
mises en scène de brèches qui excelle
dans ce style est tellement ça me fait
plaisir pour l'année qui va amener tu
joues bien trouver comment le spectacle
que tu n'as pas vu mes coups et j'ai
prouvé je les trouvais j'ai eu de très
bons échos sur le 4e et 3e
oui parce que le troisième je n'avais
pas vu non plus mais on m'avait dit
certaines choses
en général ils travaillent a pas
beaucoup de monde dans les salles d hugo
sont ces bons bien maintenant nous avons
parlé aussi vous le voulez bien des
projets à l'avenir alors avec les livres
seront donc elle en face à mon échec je
vais remercier la vapeur j'ai trouvé une
nouvelle solution je vais ouvrir un
atelier de pâte à modeler sur le plan
pratique ça coûte moins cher la pâte à
modeler et est bonne à modeler oui et en
ce qui concerne les problèmes
caractériel des adhérents ça fait moins
mal que lorsqu on arrêtera pas d'accord
alors j'ai un autre projet je voudrais
animé un atelier d'animation au former
des animateurs pour animer d'autres
ateliers
on a une équipe qui se réduit un petit
peu donc si francis propose de trouver
des gens qui nous aident non je fais en
ce qui concerne
en ce qui concerne les veillées on les
bat dont on n'est pas dans les veillées
germaris y avait beaucoup de gens qui
n'avaient rien à dire je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'ils se réunissent et qu'ils
en bas
c'est bien pour le changer de la
prochaine veillée au sujet des veillées
je m'en vais vous faire une proposition
si c'est possible j'aimerais que les
veillées se passe le matin
c'est vrai mais ce soir on aurait
peut-être plus de mentions télévisée des
matches de foot bien j'ai lu que tu
n'avais pas demandé de subvention
cette année et pour poste oui on en a
parlé si tu n'utilises pas l'argent qui
tournait cette année tu n'auras rien les
prochaines vont baisser le budget non
bon bah je crois que le mieux c'est que
halo m'hamed
oui ce soir quand tu brûleras les
feuilles mortes oui tu passes par
l'atelier danse il ya des futures études
et brûlent d'accord tu vaux le tout
comme ça on demandera de subventions que
je souhaitais commence parce que tu
comprend l'état lui donne 5 tu te prends
moi c'est le contraire mais en fait il
m'a compris que bien que toi quels sont
tes projets français et moi mes projets
j'aimerais dans mon atelier vu d'eau
parce que c'est quand même mon atelier
principal nizon j'aimerais s'il avait
été possible qu'on puisse acheter cette
année des ceintures des cinq jours parce
que parce que l'année dernière nous
avions acheté les qui m'honore et on a
beau dire
les kimonos ont tendance à tomber donc
vive cette année si on pouvait acheter
dictature ce serait bien on pas se
leurrer si tu as beaucoup d'élèves c'est
grâce à l'atelier devenu mx2 bon
d'accord mais s'il était possible
également j'aimerais des ceintures de
couleurs ça fait plaisir aux
participants et ça leur permettrait de
se reconnaître dans le corps bien alors
maintenant je vais aborder à problèmes
les problèmes de la mjc alors il ya des
problèmes graves
la machine à jus de fruits et casser
avec ses saucisses la machine annonce a
fait sont en un mois il ya des frais
convenait que nous avons changé de
gouvernement à la mairie il va falloir
acheter une lettre parce qu'avant
c'était le pc maintenant c'est le ps
pour les banderoles il va falloir
changer énormément s'élèverait donc la
fin dont on fait les efforts sur le
budget si en plus on achète des lettres
n'ont jamais eu lieu moi tu veux pas y
couper on ne peut pas y couper
bon et ensuite il ya un problème grave
c'est la faute aux l'atelier photo ils
n'ont plus de chambre noire
ce qui fait que photos nues
photo du mal de la semaine dernière sont
foutus n'ya pas les photos du mal ont
seulement non mais c'est pas vrai il
avait qu'a fait casser oui oui bah oui
mon métaux fâche n'ya rien le problème
l'atelier spéléo réclament des cordes
mais ça fait dix jours qu'ils réclament
les cordes bon dieu tu sais pas tu te
tapes a commandé les cordes ya pas de
cordes encore attends je suis défoulé
sur un jeu en ai parlé alors jacques oui
est-ce que tu t'y occuper les corps pour
l'atelier spéléo non non non mais c'est
pas possible et non mais les gosses
nikos attendre une semaine pour avis
quand il évoque ce sont en gros ça fait
dix ans qu'ils sont en cours aux
attentes des cordes c'est pas grave on
commence à ces paraboles et supprimons
mais n'accorde se comprend raconte pour
la machine à café là chez un caviste
insupportable à le régler
pour cette porte de prison qu'elle est
prisonnier sortent de leurs gonds
non c'est quand jean graille faire pipi
des pêcheurs
ça va être à nous tatiana la menace brio
à ce n'est pas sûr pas la chasse à le
faire du bruit des soldats qui n'ont
rien eu mal au froid et à regarder comme
il y en avait mais c'est comme ça
toujours avec toi tu vois un requin si
on est là c'est à cause de toi moi mais
moi je me laisse un message pas que des
bd chose à dire dans ce monde quand même
on peut le dire avec des plumes et on
s'en foutra la dgac à tous et sont
toujours cinq d'entre eux étaient
parents dans la salle
remarque c'est pas le nombre qui compte
c'est la qualité l'histoire c'est le
bouche à oreille c'est ça qui est
important pour moi c'est bien que tu
avoir fait
écoute pense à l'auteur pense à gustave
petro vie morts dans les geôles serbo
croate en 1812 on joue pour lui ce soir
ces journalistes du béribéri de change
de place allez sans doute les dernières
mais c'est une première et c'est la même
source
moi j'ai encore pipi trop vite
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] quoi les costumes
en quoi les cochons à l'arthrose est
basse et les sacs à patates ça fait
prison rôle c'est presque thil qui
s'aggrave
comment ça gratte dans les prisons ça
gratte et il faut que ça gratte pour ça
fasse vrai que c'est tout il faut jouer
pour faire passer le message
mais pourquoi tu as mis du rouge à
lèvres on vous fait des prisonniers non
mais c'est plutôt bien tant en cinq
minutes et dix dans l'année et tu
attends d un quart de belgique et est
arrivé écoute je faisais des leçons dans
une heure ce sera fini bon allez on y va
et merde
bien que je l'aïe mais j'ose pas et elle
elle ten je sais pas moi mais vous vous
voyez souvent aux belges auraient tous
les jours va alors vous en êtes où ah
ben si tu es là pour l'instant je la
regarde à travers des jumelles tu as
raison il faut y aller progressivement
ah oui oui mais alors là si tu veux je
me demande si elle m'a pas vu parce que
l'autre jour bon j'étais quand même à 65
m mais elle a regardé dans la direction
fait attention
oui alors tu m'aides bon d'accord c'est
déjà commencé
le regard mais j'ai mis paris le et je
suis coincé j'ai pas la date
enfin il faudrait voir sur un calendrier
ah oui parce que hier je l'avais la date
et aujourd'hui je vais pas là-bas il
faudrait voir à la poste un bon bon tu
sais comment il s'appelle bon ben alors
t'as qu'a laissé un blanc déjà ah oui
quand je me fais que ça à remplir après
breaking away bon alors mais commence
commences ta gueule à flatter
discrètement sur son physique
arru bombages humain je dis que là des
jolies fesses
le discret commence par les nichons oui
j'ai peut-être plus parler mon métier me
mets ton métier pour pour qu'elle te
connaisse mieux d'accord alors bon je
lui dis je suis est de volaille et
hégémonie champ mais j'aime bien vos
nichons voilà ça va la marquer ah oui on
va la marquer et je pourrais peut-être
plus parler d'eux mais vous à babré t go
et péter couleurs
n'oublie pas des couleurs ah ouais c'est
moi mes goûts déjà au baptême bien
flâner dans le métro à l'est puis j'aime
bien content et oies du ruf l'euro ouais
pe regarder les devants terawi chez le
boucher
oui et vous parlez lui de ton salaire
ah ben je suis nourrie logée remettait
les à côtés ah bah oui alors j'ai les
tickets pour les chaussures et j'ai
plusieurs cravate au secteur c'est
peut-être pas la peine de lui dire qu'on
vient de plusieurs c'est déjà bien mais
pas relevé de ton physique
ah oui bah alors j'étais à dire physique
on physique que nouveau mais physique
intéressant sur tout le visage
martin timbaut poitrail ouais je réponds
pas très bien aussi de les bras de bras
et puis c'est un bon coup de fouet que
j'ai une bonne heure de pointe - les
pieds oui parlez-lui tes pieds d'accord
avec vous je m'attendais vous ôte
presse-sports le temps joue pour toi moi
je vous donne rendez-vous pour pour jour
de la toussaint alors et une fille ça se
lève vers les 7 heures du matin non si
on en aurait alors dix ans si je 17h20
7h30
7h30 qu'elles soient bien tard à 7h30
sur la place devant les toilettes
comme ça tu peux pas la manquer dans les
postures bercy est tellement signé wit
est pas foutu après c'est moi
didon qui se termine à la troisième
entre 10 et 20 centimètres des toits à
un moment j'ai mis entre 20 et 30 ah ben
oui ce mieux on a 30 cm ouais ouais
remarques faut bien ça au et tu cela il
n'aime pas les cravates court quand ce
mouvement sur la manne alors après donc
alors si vous avez une maladie
sexuellement transmissible
alors petit à vous vous abstenez de
toute rencontre petit b vous en parlez à
votre partenaire
juste avant que je lui en parle au juste
après après ça dommage de gâcher quoi
alors après comment l'abordez-vous
petit à jean voit une lettre romantique
et un bouquet de roses petit b je lui
met la main aux fesses dans le métro
oui
oui parce que on n'a pas toujours des
tas en plus annoncé aussi d'être plus
pratique
c'est dire que moi normalement gma
gabardine ah oui on projette pas trop je
préfère une rue tu vois un peu plus
calme ouais ouais mais c'est pas écran
maintenant bon valeur b d'accord alors
vous êtes dans un lieu public
on reste que les femmes vous regarde
petit a immédiatement petit b au bout de
cinq minutes
petit c'est pas du tout à vos marques
des fois il peut y avoir deux trois
minutes
oui oui 4 5 minutes cinq civils et six
minutes produit un jour non alors ces
remarques une fois on nous a regardé
quand on pique [ __ ] devant le sex-shop
devant l'attroupement
oui il y avait une femme je rêvais
voilà la rare c'est alors la calmette
gros crayon oui
alors dans les rapports amoureux qui
prend l'initiative alors petit à vous
petit b votre femme
ça nous concerne pas il doit avec une
femme qui te prend l'initiative ou là
y'a jamais rien pour nous maintenant
d'amener un week-end petit à donner le
petit b val d'isere petit c'est à cannes
on est aussi bien en banlieue on m'a
demandé x jamais de voir un film est la
télé alors lorsque vous jouez au tennis
on quitte à vous l'a laissé gagner petit
b vous vous défendez jusqu'à la balle de
match
le tennis c'est le truc de la télé les
mecs avec mes raquettes
ouais ouais on n'est pas traitée au balo
oui mais qu'est ce qu'on m'a jamais rien
pour nous la saison et des tâches pour
les français moyens nous année des
artistes
oui oui parce que moi tu vois comment
dire mon style séducteur ce serait
plutôt discret moi je préfère rien faire
en fait ouais ouais mais ça marche
non non non ne marche pas dans les toits
moi mon truc c'est de faire rire ah oui
ça marche
non je n'ai moore spécial bons à
batailler encore une que ça j'aurais
accepteriez-vous d'avoir des rapports
avec un autre au brésil
remarque oui oui est ce que tu fais pour
le sketch on voit oui
et maintenant les diapos chérie tu as
promis l'écran mais si on regarde plus
souvent qu'il est ou bien bikélé tout
l'art regarde ta pas autre chose que de
l'écossais non on tape des draps
sentissi toute façon bas non moi je
trouve ça joli ça passe mais pas dans
leur halle est éteint la lumière clic
alors vous allez voir timothée où il est
timide je suis là je suis là rallume
il bouge parole est d'or je suis
toujours là clip clap
alors là c'est sur l'issue de museler la
dame pipi et de dos et moi je lui donne
une pépinière là combien c'était un
franc offrant cinq ans la france est
généreuse dans ces cas là moi je m'en
tiens j'y vais pas moi je fais toujours
pipier la maison à 300 me de ça vous
plaît oui original
on voit bien le voyage la série les
flops à ben alors là c'est pendant le
vol ah oui alors ça c'est l'ami revenue
à jaro là non c'est mon ses sherpas
oui là on avait un oeuf un oeuf dur
alors un oeuf dur sur le plat
c'est soit le fond plat ou l'a9 dur
c'est dans l'avion c'est pendant ces 1
oeuf dur qui était sur le plan d'accord
ok j'ai compris
puis alors à côté on avait une barquette
avec des carottes voilée ap râpez
d'accord thérapie et à côté il y avait
un autre compartiment alors avec la
moutarde le poids elle cents
et puis alors on a repris deux fois du
vin avec jeanine et on voit leurs deux
gobelets il était vite on les voit très
très mal vers l'immeuble est vide mais
oui oui oui les gobelets du on a fait
les carottes
oui et non c'est non non c'est bien
simple alors là c'est nos bagages à la
sortie de l'est vraiment d'accord
effectivement là vous voyez la valise au
premier plan oui oui oui il ya 1,5 en
cuir à côté à côté et ben derrière on
aperçoit notre valise fait pas
alors sur la gauche annonce sur la
droite
non mais derrière dans sa boule nom
d'allah bleu sur la droite mais non
c'est là que s'est levé à verte
non c'est la bleue à droite c'est la
bleue timoteï d'accord c'est la blessure
la loi mais excusez le mais il s'énerve
un peu ça c'est quand il a fait un peu
plus bas tout à l'heure on a des cas les
clubs problème là c'est là je reconnais
les palmiers sur la droite
il ya beaucoup de voitures sur cette
plage le seigneur a dont roger dubois la
voiture c'est le parquet a laissé là
l'endroit parce que quel soit environ
dans la tête la scène parquet mais joli
comme darty oui c'est un beau participer
kl au marché ses toiles
ça c'est faux je te reconnais j'ai tout
un plat alors là j'étais en réanimation
là j'avais plongé dans un endroit on
verrait bordeaux tu te moques à l'opéra
alors là c'est la mer là bas la wii
c'est le marchand de glaces sur la plage
elle est pas bien cadré à on voit juste
la tête à jeanine ah oui en arriver à
temps on connaît bien les deux boules à
roger là elle s'était parfumée à ma
famille je ne t'avais vanille café
vanille café délicate mais je n'y tiens
tu peut rallumer
pour elle c'est m je suis toujours là ça
vous a plu
non c'était oui oui oui c'est bien en
bresse et oui si on voit bien le voyage
en fin de
les bombes et d'ailleurs ça si on leur
faisait une petite surprise à oui oui
attendez attendez rester oui on allait
maintenant vous avez visité la salle de
bain tout à l'heure oui mais si on la
refait à neuf et ben les on a les photos
d'avant les travaux
r il était une fois dans le sud ouest
si futile excité à nantes encore entre
enlever l'oeil à ta mère boit rien
feignant d'artagnan m'ont tapé pendant
ce temps dans la cour du louvre
sauf le mardi c'est fermé trois joyeux
compagnons devisent gaiement porthos
athos salut les filles et trois bastille
ce nom et 3 passes tes
d'artagnan qui veut réussir dans la vie
aussi bien que son votre signe un casque
décide de rentrer dans les crs
entendez par là les compagnies royal de
sécurité remporte you tube
georges brioudes haut les mains qu est
ce que je peux faire partie de la bande
mais non j'ai crevé il est amer françois
me prodware paca mais ces petits corps
bon bah je leur donne un coup bien parce
qu'on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
le cardinal jeu c'est bientôt fini ce
bordel là c'est rien cardinal une
positif garin mptic gavage voilà pour
l'instant dans les appartements de la
reine anne d'autriche qui fournissait en
plumes tous les chapeaux des
mousquetaires à pont-croix je suis
contente de vous voir
heureusement qu'on n'habite pas
bourg-la-reine 1 ça ferait jaser avec
chilly mazarin
et mon petit cadeau qu'est ce que c'est
différent
ah j'adore les hauts faits des picards
vous pouvez sortir de l'armoire
je vous offre ces ferrer une choucroute
et un p tit coup avant de partir au non
merci m'a dit ah mais je dois rentrer
dans ses frais de rentrée la marée car à
l'époque il n'y avait pas deux millions
la choucroute la bière importée coucher
l'amour je l'étais akli débrouillards
d'artagnan à trouver un logement
et on est bien dedans enfin les
rodilhanais drague vidéo mon chéri pour
je te parle
ma patronne lan d'autruche et benzéma
rosbif alors toujours est-il qu'elle lui
a refilé cydia mais leur fout de toi et
tes potes isole les chercheurs
d'angleterre angels aubagne les matches
aller on se barre en angleterre et moi
ni mon va rater le marais car à l'époque
il n'y avait pas d'avion
les mousquetaires pense la manche
sefue nouy arrivée à londres il l'aja
buckingham palace de lady di il se
précipite sur le lit molex est bonne
mais oui il fait eric il saute sur lady
di à éviter d'être bouche il semblait
mûr et plus très bien ce qui se passe
mais j'entends le bruit la pyrale joue à
deux garçons il vit à loïc féry
l'éclairer bravo les mecs manière
générale pendant qu'un aux héroïques 0
chevaux ce jeu veauche sur leurs chevaux
cheminant sur le chemin au louvre sauf
le mardi c'est fermé le bal va commence
mais le silicium utilisé le salon fait
du loup vous ça va juste eh oui le
logiciel va ouvrir le bal
le bal est ouvert
alors non il est toujours mais non il
est ouvert aux aléas les terres bio
la haine secondes par taille on n'est
toujours pas arrivé mais te bile pas
marraine
il est toujours à leur logo 15 juil
libanais ont cherché une boîte
d'allumettes el beida revue du sort la
boîte d'allumettes les revues quand même
à leur marraine j'ai les ferries alors
il a reconnu que les loges alors à
défaut gagnons tous pour un et un
couscous torah et un pousse pousse alors
dix compagnons
bonjour les grands titres du journal
sociale politique culture si on a le
temps et tiercé social dans le conflit
qui oppose les deux parties à savoir la
délégation patronale et la délégation
syndicale
des changements sont intervenus un porte
parole de la délégation patronale a
déclaré après les entretiens bilatéraux
de la nuit dernière après qu'a été
établi clairement la légitimité
réciproque des revendications des
partenaires en présence
les discussions ont porté sur les points
litigieux dans le but d'apporter des
aménagements aux propositions liminaire
de résolution du conflit initial étant
entendu que celle ci n'était pas
exclusive de toute initiative pouvant
contribuer à la mort d'un processus de
résolution ne serait ce que partielle
des points les plus essentiels du
conflit dans la mesure et cette seule
mesure où les labels l'élaboration et la
conception d'une nouvelle structure
permettrait une plus grande facilité de
communication entre les deux parties et
ouvrait bien entendu la fois à une
nouvelle forme de dialogue d'ouverture
et de processus tendant à la
concrétisation des objectifs à réaliser
à noter la réponse immédiate du porte
parole de l'autre délégation qui a été
non maintenant tiercé vos pronostics
oui mes pronostics le neuf le 14 le 12
le 15 le 4 le 3 le 2 le 28 le 1 le 42 à
le 17 le 7 et le 18 le 21 le 425 2039 le
6 et le 4 nous avons interrogés n'ont
pas l'entraîneur on a l'habitude de la
voir sur le plateau l'entraîneur pour
lui demander son pronostic
aujourd'hui nous avons décidé
d'interroger directement le cheval le
favori de la course
il est
la folie de lui donner comme c'est comme
ça voilà
e le cheval de marne est favori demain
favorite je suis bien qu'est ce que vous
pensez de mon pronostic
eh bien j'ai toutes mes chances je dois
le dire j'ai tout péché bien vous voyez
dans le tiercé de dimanche
comment se suivra évidemment je me vois
puisque je suis partant alors je vais y
aller tout y est je vais y être mais
voit évidemment je vais partir oui je
veux dire vous voyez dans les trois
premiers c'est à dire que le problème
c'est que la dernière fois à chantilly
de la 15 jours j'ai malheureusement eu
un handicap de 150 kg et de 10 mètres et
de jours non de 150 m et à l'heure des
bilans et j'ai eu un petit problème
et tandis que les huit jours à maisons
laffitte j'ai malheureusement eu un
handicap ou encore pire vêtements
puisque le terrain était très sec qui -
vous êtes mis un terrain sec
non c'est pas que je dise ça dépend du
temps si ces maudits ce n'est pas
vraiment un bien s'il pleut il est
mouillé se voyait donc il faut pas que
ce soit très sexy non c'est en fait ça
dépend du temps c'est à dire que dans
les lignes droites
ça va à peu près par terra mouillé mais
si le terrain c'est dans les courbes
j'ai tendance à passer sur la corde et
avec mes sabots parce que j'ai des faire
n'est-ce pas qu'ils sont pas anti des
rapports et la première
comment je me pose problème pour passer
à une droite
or ce qu'il faut c'est un terrain sec
taille droite est mouillé dans les cours
alors là je vous avait bon moral
mais ce problème c'est au niveau du des
pronostics que j'ai je pense que je
serai le gagnant c'est sûr c'est sûr
c'est bien fait votre say there are les
autres facteurs qui vous chers amis je
pense produire ou les outsiders je pense
qu'il ya roquettes un technique de
plongeon qu'est ce que vos jeux prévert
ariane mnouchkine une petite jument team
agréable et de douce fabrique est
vraiment la meilleure pouliche très
plaisir
un étalon le gros lot je pense puisqu'il
s'agit tu va très certainement c'est
léon zitrone
merci bonsoir bonsoir
jeanne d'arc aînés afin sol mais l'on
dampremy adoré après un stage au bois de
boulogne
elles passent rapidement son cap2
bergère est cool
une jeunesse paisible dans les verts
pâturages lors un bon lit moutons s'il
vous plaît les moutons travail et
moutons ont repris des votants ligaturer
ma mère dans la salle ces propositions
allaient aller 1-4
et nous retrouvons jeanne d'arc plus
belle que jamais
sont les moutons jeanne d'arc que vous
êtes déjà une star c'est vous qui dites
qu'est ce que vous faites avec la laine
de vos moutons pastry côté tueur le
moment de temps qui passe et jeanne
d'arc à saint ouen à cjad a lancé roy
c'est génial ma hanche droite et moi
mais ce jour ne fut pas un jour comme
les autres sa radio se brouilla à café
hier à tout faire y est radio paris et
danger elle entendit des voies occupées
heureux
jeanne d'or va bout tu ne sens du mot et
je vais voter les anglais c'était
charles gabriel qu'il a plu affolée elle
réunit un attelage de fortune et courant
vise à la cloche
rousseau en jour c'est dingue j'ai une
nouvelle incroyable talent ça y est il
est perdu maintenant qu'est ce que
raconte j'entends des voix
faut déjà y brouter les anglais en
offrant put abouti dans leur de france
ça y est ça recommence mais aussi moins
banal bon vous devez les pousser
d'écouté pas cette conne toi si tu veut
pas bosser pour moi tu restes tout et
personne ne veut y croire
incomprise de tous elle prend le tgv il
fonce à chinon au château de charles vii
jeu super vite donc c'est incroyable
mais j'entends des voix faut que j'aille
bouter les anglais hors de france
j'aurais des voies ferrées en rendez
vous électoral sur ma personne ils
veulent croire
elle arrive au château du roi bonjour
fier hallebardiers que j'aille voir le
roi parce qu'il faut que j'aille brouter
les ans des enfants
un postulant les anglais alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait en sport est survenu
mégaphone un camarade un bar gay
assemblée générale à 10 heures dans le
grand réfectoire n'oubliez pas vos
cartes de conti merci peuvent l'être ça
me reprend chante encore des voix je
vais utiliser un stratagème
oh la jolie girafe à doit y avoir ni
elle savait déjouer tous les pièges
bonjour mon roi dites moi j'ai entendu
des voix faut que j'aille brouter les
anglais en france
alors qu'est ce que je dois faire ses
besoins de ce soir oui bah il faudrait
une armure oui jean claude une armure
c'est froid
non je n'y crois pas bon et maintenant
tu te casses on va voter ambiant de
france se discute pas elle se fait
encercler
mais pour chasser les anglais et l'usaid
un nouveau stratagème à ils et cinq au
moins grande et je tends une bien trop
froid ils sont cons ces anglais trahi
par les siens et par son roi elle est
arrêtée
je ferai dans la nuit beh de brouter les
anglais on ressent alors se déguise
c'est mardi gras bas puisque je vous dis
fille jeanne bar est sain et moi je suis
là polo au lycée philippe bouvard a
longtemps mené
elle est jugée par le clergé que préside
le tristement célèbre évêque cochon ses
veaux cochons
ah non moi ça lisse et le port accusée
vous quelque chose à dire pour votre
défense
oui aucun et broughton avec cochon on
peut penser vous la situation
pensez vous qu'il est coupable
monsieur attendu que le jury si présent
reconnu coupable de sorcellerie la
prévenue répondant au patronyme de
jeanne d'arc habitants du litre de la
chapelle à ton avis attendu que le crime
de sorcellerie re passible de la peine
de mort jeanne d'arc sera condamné ce
point être puni par le plus chez soi
écouter un disque dur et met 400 sont
brûlés mois
au pas ses bourreaux marcel merci allez
vas-y marcel chauffe
vous connaissez michael est de retour
bonjour son attitude à mon niveau 3
qu'est ce que vous faites est alors à
quoi ça sert que du crush cet égard 4
mesdames et messieurs afin de pallier la
longueur excessive du roman nous allons
vous en montrer une version légèrement x
purger mais néanmoins très fidèle au
début jean valjean est arrêtée pour le
vol d'une baguette de luge en maintenant
les misérables j'ai très faim car je
suis misérable mais je vois j'aurais
bien les bonne baguette de pain oui unis
bonjour la boulangère bonjour mais ses
clients je vous en supplie dans supplée
donnez moi une baguette gbagbo l'aumône
seulement données web baguette de pain
vous en supplie ils m'attendent riz le
goût g et si je cède histoire ne tient
pas je ne vous regarde pas voler la
baguette remplacer un supplément gratuit
la voie orale ciblant des 120 tempête
implique qu'ils soient petit bien-être
fallait c'était j'avais j'avais j'avais
une bonne pâte ses volumes à la baguette
oui bah là vous êtes tués damned je
crois que j'ai fini de manger mon pain
blanc je suis grillé aller en prison
ce faire la sirène ouais on y va
les condamnés à vingt ans au bagne de
fleury mérogis il y connaît ici ici les
studios à vos philippe de dieuleveult
oui c'est mon dieu oui je suis
actuellement dans la tour
samba sow
tenu par les durs banjo vous n'avez vu
passer peut-être je les ai vus dans un
match paris saint germain tac je vais
les voir alors s'il ya un footballeur
dans la salle peut-être au méchoui le
personnage au moins ce côté trop chaud
malchance je levais l'interroger
monsieur vous êtes toujours maggio nous
allons pouvoir prendre venue ponctuer
venise avec moi et nous allons regagner
les socios
rypien personne qui est capable de faire
hélicoptère si jean marchand seule fille
jeux verts a tout de suite compris
il atterrit chez un curé de campagne et
c'est le veulent des chandeliers
d'argents trek à lancieux je viens pour
l'épisode deschamps l'a mis l'argent est
d'accord ils sont sûrs et cheminées la
voiture et j'ai bien dit dodo était pour
le vol la démission des fédérations et
unions vous êtes jean valjean la des
misérables bas il faut bien meilleur
fois l'hymne là aussi du terme de goût
la bible est recyclé dans les classes a
livré continuer à la rentrée on
reconnaissait inspecteur rovère et du
théâtre de bouvard
non non des misérables sera bon pour
connaissez j'aurai des gens super un
immonde
j'ai passé en sortant de chez vous je le
dis que vous lui avez donné les
chandeliers d'argents il devrait au
méchant de lier la rive abolie mais tu
lui donnes les chandeliers c'est dans
l'histoire qu'un poème en août a promis
le sketch on a répété tout à apprendre
et pour toi mais tu apprends un bouquin
j'ai pour lui porter la toque quelque
154 il donne est changée de l'argent
alors bon bah je suis en train de relire
la bible
bon ok autant pour moi alors je paie
donne là ok je suis né donne pas les
clefs
ouais ok pas les 150 pages plus loin
c'est la scène entre fantine et jean
valjean rien moi qu'est ce que ça fait
de la scène entre fontaine et jean
valjean qu'est ce que vous faites
fantine rongé par la maladie et à bas et
abandonné de tout se vend ses cheveux et
ses dents bonjour dix mois donne moi tes
cheveux et donne-moi dompter dans un des
dons merci alors 3 3 frontières plaisent
hobby détient une bonne boule de neige
dont il fallait qu'elle nourrit sa
petite fille elle est même amené à
vendre son corps
ah ben je sais pas mais tout ne nous
fait peur mais luis rego
ah bon voilà comment roth le meilleure
séquence baissière
je suis triste dans mon coin sombre
je suis jean valjean toujours et je suis
toujours misérables et maintenant je
suis un peu plus riches et j'avais sauvé
les misérables au poutine jamais été dit
maintenant il faut frottis est
malheureuse d'esprit chimie il va sauver
concept ma petite fille oui ça fait
quand sa fille l'a fait l'été dernier
oui d'accord d'accord je veux sauver la
chaussée
elle fait appel elle voulait parler de
cause alors attends moi dis moi dis moi
franchement comment je ferais pour
connaître l'avis de mes engage ma
dernière d'aller jouer oui c'est bien
moi ça
avec ça je pouvais le reconnaîtra donc
ça va je cours je vous suis via un roman
c'est là allait donner lieu plus tard un
roman célèbre autant en emporte la dent
jean valjean arrive j'ai les thénardier
well robes on en ferait au jour est ce
que c'est je suis jean magendie
nigériane
c'est ça puis moi je suis victor hugo et
ça c'est un misérable on lui donne
quelques jours j'ai déjà donné
on a déjà donné je pour cause est la
fille amandine il vient pour concept
mêlant l'épatant de cause et autres
l'importante cause et on travaille bien
pour la fille de fantine tu as
connaissant tisse sa mère font-ils pas
une preuve
bruges pour wii tient la voix
j'avais bien qu'elle avait une dent
contre moi alors tu vas me dire où tu
allais crouzet elle est elle est en
sûreté au fond du pur à qui la torture
non elle fait la vaisselle et c'est la
jeune scène un trait fawcett et jean
valjean
yaalon qui s'était bel à l'essai par
jacky l'aspiq a longuement gâcha
ligthart 4 les verts et les connards moi
que je l'appelle vettel ondine cause et
non tu la fille de fond qui n'est ce pas
je suis jean valjean des misérables mais
je viens pour te sauver et moi je suis
connais tu vas te plairait un petit
cadeau cette poupée gentil monsieur où
je vais te la chercher
cool
tout au long
bien semer des jeunes à tous
bien qu'une seule personne qui est
capable de s'offrir des poupées aux
petites filles c'est jean valjean et de
vue tout ne se joue au ballon
vingt ans plus tard jean valjean devient
riche et c'est l'épisode de la charrette
s'étonner de lourdes
faites attention vous avez deux chars
action à l'aide au monsieur relevé cette
charrette elle est trop lourd je suis
coincé dessous on peut pas je vais
plonger et appelaient aussi gentil c'est
quoi ces de l'otan fait pas tout quoi
c'est l'autre jaber c'est moi son agent
des misérables je suis à sauver des
misères au monsieur nom de dieu qu'avoir
un pauvre braves pour goods quelque 1
600 une malheureuse l'autre charette a
argué du mans braves et bien je suis un
homme
la fois ci le pauvre est faux bond je
suis un pauvre bougre et je suis
actuellement coincés sous cette
charrette il ya joué sauver car je suis
un belge en convient c'est gentil gars
qui me plaît et qui seule personne qui
est capable de soulever de charrette
avec ses propres mains c'est jean
valjean c'est pas jean majeau
mais alors il ya bien un corps dans la
seine killen souricette chaque jeu
s'offrant celui qui se soulèvent les
chars et un sang-froid nos produits 200
francs à celui qui soulève la charrette
303 emprunt
diallo non non il pour 1 400 points je
sais ce seront six enfants monsieur grh
oui monsieur 700 francs mais les soeurs
bliss enfants et la sem encore personnes
contestant prend 900 francs j'offre mes
ventes pour soulever cette charrette à
noisy à lens dépêche de francs monsieur
tout internet
oui mille fois pour mille fois je le
fais tout seul
dites à personne qui ouais on cesse jean
valjean nous sautons là plusieurs
passages qui n'ont aucun intérêt comme
la révolution française
un épisode assez peu ragoûtant
d'ailleurs sur les égouts de paris ainsi
que les pilotes qui n'a aucun intérêt je
les lui - même faites moi confiance et
nous enchaînons sur notre dame de paris
jusqu'à ce jour résultat le relais belge
a personne qui est capable de se
déguiser en chaire et jean marchand
je vous arrête tout le monde a vu le
film